there is an old occult book called The  shamsalm Arif or the son of knowledge  this is a book that has an Infamous  reputation as being basically the most  dangerous book in the entire world the  Samsung is attributed to a 13th century  Sufi figure called Ahmed al-buni the  Sham Salma Arif the actual book that we  have today that is so famous and so  feared actually appears for the first  time in the 17th century and so the  consensus among Scholars today is that  this is actually not a work by Ahmed  al-buni but a compilation a collection  of various different writers and  different authors from across history  from the 13th century all the way up to  the 17th century there seems to be a  core section of the book that is  traceable to Ahmad himself so he did  write a portion of the book but the  majority of it is by later authors who  were inspired by him and who also wrote  on various are called Sciences